ذكية للرد والصينيون يبهرون
العالم كالعادة وبسلاح تقشعر
الابدان ورئيس كوريا الجنوبية في
مرمى اهداف مسيرات كيم وسول
تعلنها لقد نفذ صبرنا واردوغان
يطبع مع الجميع فهل تنجح الخطة?
اسبانيا تتغزل بالجزائر وعدوى
الفشل اللبناني تنتقل لواشنطن
والجنيه المصري يلفظ انفاسه
الاخيرة.
الحرب الاستخباراتية يشتعل
فتيلها. خلال الحروب يكون دور
الاستخبارات هو الابرز لتوجيه
بوصلة الجيوش لادارة الحروب. لكن
ما بين صحة الاخبار واخطائها قد
تغرق الجيوش او تفقد مصداقيتها
هنا رئيس الاستخبارات العسكرية
الاوكرانية كيريلو بودانوف يعلن
انه يحتكم على معلومات مؤكدة من
مصادر بشرية بشأن صحة الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين تايلاند بوتين في
حالة صحية حرجة وسوف يموت بسرعة
كبيرة وامل حقا في هذا. وفق ايه
بي سي الامريكية. الرد جاء من
وزيرة الخارجية الفرنسية كورونا
التي قالت ربما هذا ما يتمناه هو
خصوصا انه قال حرفيا اتمنى.
ليخرج بوتين من مرضه ان كان
مريضا حقا ليعلن لنظيره التركي
اردوغان انفتاح موسكو على الحوار
بشأن اوكرانيا اذا التزمت كييه
بالمتطلبات وقبلت الوقائع
الجديدة على الارض وفقا لوكالة
الصحافة الفرنسية ميدانيا وعلى
ارض المعارك. الاركان الاوكرانية
تعلن ان قواتها شنت خمسا وعشرين
غارة على المواقع الروسية. بينما
اكد الجيش الاوكراني ان القوات
الروسية شنت اكثر من ثمانية
وستين هجوما صاروخيا البنية
التحتية في خرسون وزبروجة وخركيف
ودينيبرو. لتصيب النشوة
الاوكران. ويعلن رئيس
الاستخبارات العسكرية الاوكرانية
انه من المرجح ان تكون هناك
ضربات اخرى في عمق الاراضي
الروسية وقال ان الهجمات ستأتي
اعمق واعمق داخل روسيا. رد
القوات الروسية كان على الارض
حيث احرزت تقدما تدريجيا في
الايام الماضية في باخموت بحسب
رويترز يدعو حلفاء بلاده الى ان
يحذو حذو الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون
الذي اعلن ان بلاده ستسلم
اوكرانيا دبابات قتالية ذات
تصميم غربي في سابقة هي الاولى
من نوعها. فيما اعلن الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ان فكرة ارسال
مركبات من نوع برادلي القتالية
مطروحة على طاولة النقاش. وها
نحن الرد الروسي على كل هذه
الخطوات الغربية كالعادة. لكن من
جهة اخرى هناك من يرفض دعم كييه
ببعض الاسلحة يقول الامين العام
لمجلس الامن القومي الاوكراني
اوليكسي دانيلوف ان رفض المستشار
الالماني اولف جولدز تزوير كييه
بالدبابات سيؤدي لنقل المعركة
الى حدود برلين واشتود جارت على
حد قوله فهل هو تهديد اوكراني
للالمان لدى وزيرة الخارجية
الالمانية انلينا بيربوك والتي
قالت ان الاتحاد الاوروبي بذل
قصارى جهده لوقف الحرب لكن
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين لم
يكن يفكر في شيء سوى تدمير البلد
المجاور له. وبالعودة للحرب
الاوكرانية تحاول روسيا من الجو
ارهاق اوكرانيا على الارض من
خلال الطائرات بدون طيار المفخخة
رخيصة الثمن التي تجلبها ايران.
موسكو تجاوزت خطة تدمير الاهداف
الاوكرانية الى استنزاف كييف
فكلفة الصاروخ الاوكراني الذي
يسقط مسيرات موسكو هو اغلى من
المسيرات بسبعة اضعاف وهكذا تخطط
موسكو لاضعاف كييف والغرب على
المدى الطويل. ليمد الغرب كييف
بنظام جديد غير مجرى المعارك انه
النظام الرقمي وهي استراتيجية
سهلت اصطياد القوات الروسية في
ساحات القتال حيث تسمح الانظمة
الرقمية بادارة ومتابعة الجيوش
الروسية. فهل ستصمت روسيا? الصين
تبهر الامريكان. الصين في
المقدمة والعالم يدرك هذه
الحقيقة والغرب في قلق دائم. نعم
يا سادة بكين تواصل ابهارها
العسكري وتطلق اولى تجارب حاملة
الطائرة الجديدة فوجيان الاكثر
تطورا اسطولها البحري. وهي اكبر
سفينة بحرية صنعتها الصين على
الاطلاق. وتم تحديث المعدات
وطائرات جديدة على متن حاملة
الطائرات. فان الوجهة يا اصحاب
العيون الضيقة قد تكون تايوان هي
الوجهة وذلك باعلان تايبي انها
احتجزت ثلاثة ضباط بالاضافة الى
ضابط متقاعد بسلاح الجو وذلك
للاشتباه في تجسسهم لصالح الصين
لكن ليست الا لقمة صغيرة
للصينيين. ليعلنها الامين العام
لحلف الاطلسي انسولتنبرج محذرا
من الخطر الصيني قائلا يجب الا
تؤثر تجارتنا مع الصين على
امننا. لينضم اليه الرئيس السابق
للحلف اندرس فوجراس موسن بقوله
انه يتعين على القوى الاوروبية
بذل المزيد من الجهد لثني الصين
عن الهجوم على تايوان بما في ذلك
الاستعداد لفرض اقتصادية مؤلمة
وتدريب القوات التايوانية فهل
تجرؤ دول اوروبا على خطوة كهذه?
كيم يتحرش عسكريا. بطرق ذكية
ومجنونة? ها هو يواجه خصومه بل
جنون فن يجيده كيم جونغ ولا احد
غيره. ووسط كل تلك التوترات
المستمرة مع بيونج يانج كشف
مسؤول عسكري في كوريا الجنوبية
احدى الطائرات المسيرة التي
اطلقتها كوريا الشمالية مؤخرا
دخلت لفترة وجيزة منطقة حظر جوي
بالقرب من مكتب الرئيس يونس كيول
في سول بحسب وكالة يونهب. فيا
للرعب الذي بثه المجنون لجيرانه
ليقول لزعيمهم كوش ملك اوشهمت
كما يقولها الاتراك. وبعد سلسلة
الاستفزازات العسكرية من كوريا
الشمالية الجارة الجنوبية ينفذ
صبرها. وضاقت ذرعا بما يفعله كيم
لترد وتهدد بتعليق الاتفاق
العسكري المبرم عام الفين
وتمانية عشر لوقف كل التصرفات
العدائية في حال اختراق مجالها
الجوي مرة اخرى. الية اردوغان
الذكي. الالية تتغير والخطط
تتبدل وبخطوات مدروسة تتعامل
تركيا مؤخرا. فها هو الرئيس
التركي اردوغان يجري اتصالا
هاتفيا بنظيره الروسي بوتين
للوساطة في حرب اوكرانيا ولكن
الملف السوري كان حاضرا وبقوة
والنتيجة تظهر فورا. باعلان وزير
الدفاع التركي خلوصي اكار
امكانية توسيع الدوريات المشتركة
مع روسيا شمالي سوريا بالاتفاق
مع دمشق. واضاف هاكار انه اكد
خلال الاجتماع الثلاثي مع موسكو
ودمشق ان غير قادرة على استضافة
مزيد من اللاجئين السوريين.
التغيير التركي يتواصل انقرة
تدخل فصلا اخر من تطبيع العلاقات
وليس مع سوريا فقط. حيث قال
المتحدث باسم الرئاسة التركية
ابراهيم جلن ان تطبيع العلاقات
بين مصر وتركيا سيتسارع مؤكدا
امكانية تعيين سفراء لدى
الدولتين بحسب وكالة الاناضول.
احداث والتطورات. اسبانيا تغازل
الجزائر مجددا وتسعى لاعادة
علاقات البلدين الى مسارها
الطبيعي وفتح صفحة جديدة بين
البلدين مع مدح مدريد لوفاء
الجزائر بعقود الغاز معهم رغم
توتر العلاقات مؤخرا. الجنيه
المصري يختتم العام ضمن قائمة
اسوأ عشر عملات في العالم باكثر
من ستة وعشرين جنيه للدولار
الواحد وترقب شعبي لارتفاع
الاسعار. استمرار اضراب اكثر من
اربعين الف عامل في شبكة السكك
الحديدية في بريطانيا وشلل في
حركة النقل بسبب مطالبة العمال
بتحسين الرواتب لكن دون جدوى حتى
الان. وسوناك يدعو للحوار. مجلس
النواب الامريكي يفشل للمرة
السادسة في اختيار رئيس جديد له.
فهل حمى الفشل اللبنانية اليكم
ايها الامريكان اصدر القضاء
الامريكي اول حكم بالاعدام في
تاريخه بحق امرأة متحولة جنسيا
اتهمت بقتل شركتها السابقة وهي
بذلك ايضا اول شخص يتم اعدامه
هناك في عام الفين وثلاثة
وعشرين. يصر الغرب والاوكران على
تأكيد اصابة بوتين بمرض خطير.
فهل يعد مرض بوتين للغربيين